si tu bienestar es para ti y
específicamente ese punto ha sido tomado
en cuenta por parte del consejo nacional
electoral y tiene que ver
específicamente con el tiempo y cómo se
conformaron los distintos centros
receptores del voto el consejo nacional
electoral inclusive emitió un comunicado
donde él comunicó cuáles fueron los
resultados de conformación de cada uno
de los centros es que de los centros
conformados al menos el 68 34 por ciento
fueron instalados con miembros
principales y de igual forma un
aproximado del 31 por ciento se instaló
tanto con personas que estaban en la
fila como miembros suplente y por eso se
visualizó estas filas y que se
realizaron en algunos de los centros de
votación pero a esta obra ya el 100% de
los centros electorales están
conformados e inclusive ya el órgano
comicial expreso que al menos el 12 por
ciento 12 50% de los electores habían
ejercido el derecho al sufragio a esta
hora en ecuador en este momento él
también puede visualizarse como el 80,3
por ciento de las organizaciones
políticas se mantiene en veedores
observadores en los
centros de votación más sin embargo
continúa realizándose en las votaciones
de manera muy fluida a esta hora yo me
encuentro en uno de los principales
centros de votación de quito donde puede
visualizarse un flujo continuo entrada y
salida de los electores
gustavo andré zarautz ya guillermo lazo
que se están disputando esta segunda
vuelta sólo los separaron 13 puntos en
la primera jornada electoral en ese
momento ya q pérez que era el candidato
indígena quedó por fuera y ahora llama
al voto nulo qué efecto tendrá esto
entre los electores
básicamente el voto nulo históricamente
en el ecuador no ha sobrepasado el 63
por ciento desde en 1978 el voto nulo
aproximadamente en unas elecciones en
este país las más altas estuvieron
aproximadamente en el año 2017 han
habido algunos porcentajes como el 11,3
por ciento 96 por ciento 8,6 por ciento
o 6,3 por ciento hay que tomar en cuenta
que el voto un nulo se fortalece en la
segunda vuelta electoral pero para tener
una idea por lo menos en la primera
vuelta electoral sufragaron 10 millones
de personas y se requiere en este país
que más del 50% es sufragar de esta
manera del voto nulo para poder así
anular las las elecciones esto quiere
decir que debieron haber votado por lo
menos más de 5,3 millones de personas
para conseguir este efecto el órgano
comicial ha dicho que este no será una
problemática para anular las elecciones
pero los movimientos indígenas intentan
por lo menos alcanzar un 20 por ciento
para llamar así el voto nulo y
expresarse con una protesta social